la bambola ne abbiamo ne abbiamo sempre
avuta fin da piccoli una preferita era
lei nessuna poteva uguagliarlo restava
la nostra amica fedele pronta a
consolarci quando qualcosa ci faceva
piangere pronto a coccolarci prima di
prendere sonno la nostra compagna di
giochi la custode dei nostri più
profondi segreti la nostra bambola
preferita
lei si muove con noi i suoi gesti sono i
nostri frutto di una fantasia così
concreta che sembra realtà e non si
finisce mai di restare bambini sia
sempre voglia di giocare e anche questa
volta si tratta di un gioco un gioco
bellissimo in cui io sono la tua bambola
tu sei la mia io muovo le tue gambe tu
le mie braccia e insieme formiamo un
unico corpo perfetto e nato tutto così
come un semplice intreccio di energia
un'intesa così unica che nemmeno ci
siamo resi conto di come passava il
tempo di come i nostri gesti andavano
riempire la musica perfettamente senza
limiti senza paura volavamo insieme
unite in un unico corpo ea volte così
difficile raccontare una storia vera
a volte così doloroso ripensare ad un
passato che resta sempre presente
inesorabile ad ogni risveglio
a volte invece così semplice così
spontaneo così bello
a volte la musica sembra scritta apposta
per noi
gli incontri le persone capitano come
angeli sul nostro cammino
e così è tutto facile il risveglio di
una bambola malata
il rifiuto di se stessa il funerale
della bambola il rigetto l'alienazione
la disperazione la passività poi il sole
la luce la presa di coscienza
un'esistenza diversa ma bellissima la
bambola nuova la nostra bambola nuova
buonasera a tutti è un piacere essere
qui ho le gambe un po ancora emozionato
scusatemi
niente oggi sono qui per raccontarvi la
mia storia per portare una testimonianza
e soprattutto per raccontarvi un
progetto bellissimo che è nato da
pochissimi mesi ma che mi sta dando
tantissime emozioni e tantissima energia
per parlare di me vorrei iniziare da una
foto da una foto che mi vede ritratta
con i miei fratelli e mio babbo
semplicemente non c'e la mia mamma
perché ha sempre preferito rimanere
dietro le quinte e quindi io l'ho
rispettata in questa sua questo modo di
essere
parto da qui perché loro ci sono sempre
stati sia nei momenti più difficili che
nei momenti di gioia e mi hanno sempre
appoggiato nelle scelte e nei grandi
cambiamenti grazie ai genitori da
piccola mi sono avvicinata allo sport ho
iniziato a 9 anni ginnastica ritmica
testata prima di tutto una passione una
passione che mi ha accompagnata per
tutta l'adolescenza e direi che mi ha
vista crescere e mi ha aiutato a
crescere
comunque ho trascorso la maggior parte
del tempo libero in palestra fino a che
alta di 14 anni appunto è arrivata la
convocazione nella nazionale di
ginnastica ritmica e così è arrivato il
primo cambiamento mi sono trasferita a
milano in quel periodo la il centro
federale era milano e quindi a milano ho
vissuto tre anni
sicuramente molto faticosi che mi hanno
insegnato il sacrificio la disciplina e
che però mi hanno comunque reso
tantissime soddisfazioni e comunque
partecipazione a varie competizioni
internazionali fino appunto arrivare a
a partecipare alle olimpiadi quindi
diciamo a coronare quello che è il sogno
di ogni atleta
dopo l'esperienza el in politica ho
scelto di lasciare la ginnastica perché
avevo un altro obiettivo a cui dedicarmi
un sogno che ho sempre avuto ossia
quello di laurearmi in ingegneria e così
mi sono trasferita appunto a firenze
dove ho seguito
diciamo la carriera universitaria e
durante la quale però mi sono avvicinata
alla danza conosciuto quest'arte
meravigliosa che mi ha insegnato tanto
ancora e mi ha ancora aiutata a crescere
ho lavorato in una compagnia di danza di
firenze appunto florence dance company
fino a quando diciamo nel 2008 è
arrivato un grandissimo cambiamento
una mattina lunedì mattina un dolore
improvviso alla schiena mi ha svegliata
poche dopo poche ore mi sono subito resa
conto che qualcosa non andava comunque
cominciava a perdere sia la sensibilità
che il movimento agli arti inferiori
quindi in poco tempo il trasferimento in
ospedale l'operazione e al risveglio mi
è stato annunciato che non avrei più
camminato non è stato chiaramente
facilissimo perché i sentimenti le
emozioni che si alternavano erano
diversi e anche contrastanti l'uno con
l'altro sicuramente tanta paura paura di
non sapere cosa mi aspettasse tanta
incredulità ma anche alternata a momenti
di speranza
diciamo che ho avuto la fortuna
istintivamente di lasciarmi di fidarmi
di affidarmi alle persone che intorno mi
stavano insegnando ad affrontare una
nuova condizione nella quotidianità
proprio e quindi ho preferito in un
certo senso non guardarmi troppo allo
specchio ma anzi guardare dentro me
stessa comunque mi sentivo sempre la
nicoletta di sempre è così ponendomi
piccoli obiettivi ogni giorno il tempo
passava
dopo sei mesi in ospedale sono stata
dimessa e diciamo lì è stato forse il
momento più difficile perché secondo me
tutti i limiti tutte appunto le
disabilità sono più limitanti in
funzione in relazione a quello che è
l'ambiente che ci circonda e quindi
sicuramente trovarsi in un mondo che
conoscevo però in un altra condizione
era arrivato lì il momento forse più
difficile
così mi sono aggrappata a quello che era
un obiettivo che avevo per un po
lasciato da parte
mi sono dedicato allo studio così mi
mancavano due esami e stavo preparando
la thai la tesi è così
nel solo un anno dopo mi sono laureata e
ho potuto iniziare
diciamo a lavorare come libera
professionista come ingegnere civile
lavoro che porta avanti tuttora quindi
diciamo che la mia vita aveva assunto
nuovamente una normalità
avevo comunque ricercato
quell'indipendenza riprendendo la
patente tornando a vivere da sola però
c'era ancora qualcosa che sicuramente
mancava così ha deciso di ri
confrontarmi rimettermi in gioco
nuovamente con lo sport
ho iniziato dal tennis in carrozzina uno
sport che mi ha aiutato tantissimo a
trovare a ritrovare fiducia in me stessa
e soprattutto a confrontarmi con quel
limite che spesso magari anche la
fisioterapia ti porta un po a odiare no
perché comunque questo continuo
confronto con un qualcosa che non potrà
mai migliorare quindi arriva a un certo
punto anche un po una frustrazione
invece nello sport come appunto poi ho
avuto modo di imparare anche a sciare
sono poi le potenzialità no quello che
ti aiutano a capire che si può tutto e
così diciamo in quel periodo mi sentivo
un po come diciamo una mosca senza testa
perché ho provato così tante cose ma
proprio perché avevo bisogno di
ritrovarmi di riconoscermi poi un giorno
per curiosità sono voluta tornare nella
scuola di danza dove pertanto avevo
lavorato lì ho rincontrato il coreografo
con cui appunto avevo lavorato durante
le università e che mi ha proposto di
danzare un pezzo con lui naturalmente
inizialmente no no assolutamente ma come
sempre
l'inizio con il no e poi provo
durante lo spettacolo che si è svolto a
firenze ho conosciuto una persona una
persona veramente speciale che a silvia
silvia che mi ha travolta completamente
con un'energia incredibile era
propositiva su milioni di fronti è
arrivata proponendomi tantissime cose e
penso i primi mesi di averla guardata
con gli occhi sbarrati molto perplessa
poi il giorno si è arrivata con green
green è un carrello diciamo un carrello
in ferro che silvia ha ideato e
progettato per me pensando al modo che
meglio mi avrebbe fatto sentire in un
palco più che altro perché per ritrovare
quella libertà di movimento che diciamo
avevo perso
e quindi anche qui sapevo che era una
persona molto particolare ma mai avrei
pensato fosse arrivata potesse arrivare
a tanto
però a quel punto non potevo tirarmi
indietro e quindi sono salita su grimm
questi sono i due fabbriche hanno
aiutato silvia a realizzare il carrello
e niente da lì ho cominciato ad
allenarmi e coinvolgendo un'amica
coreografa che ha coreografato e danzato
con noi la coreografa toe il pezzo è
danzato con noi
il pezzo che è andato per la prima volta
sul palco a settembre dell'anno scorso è
stata un'emozione incredibile più che
altro mi sono trovata veramente a mio
agio energia pura che quindi non si
poteva fermare lì quindi a quel punto ho
lasciato via libera silvia la quale
aveva in mente un progetto ancor più
grande ha cominciato a coinvolgere vari
artisti quindi siamo musicisti che
danzatori e così abbiamo insieme fondato
la compagnia inoltre che vede in questo
momento cinque musicisti e quattro
danzatori appunto portare in giro lo
spettacolo assenza assenza perché nello
spettacolo comunque si vuol
si parla di assenza di mancanze che
possono essere appunto mancanze fisiche
ma non solo ognuno di noi nella vita si
trova a provare dei momenti a
confrontarsi con i momenti magari di
mancanza e secondo noi il messaggio
appunto che vogliamo trasmettere è che
prima di tutto il primo passo è quello
di accettare la propria mancanza non
tanto accettare ma soprattutto
confrontarsi e prendere coscienza di
questa mancanza e da lì iniziare appunto
a ad aprirsi a nuove opportunità è il
pezzo che per me è il cuore dello
spettacolo è proprio il pezzo della
bambola che avete visto poco fa nel
quale io sono il busto e silvia e le
gambe si parla la coreografia parla di
una bambola appunto una bambola che si
ammala una bambola che inizialmente non
accetta quello che è successo quindi
muore e dal momento che arriva invece la
presa di coscienza
arriva anche la rinascita quindi una
nuova una nuova rinascita in qualcosa di
originale di particolare e in questo
percorso abbiamo avuto la fortuna di
incontrare e giancarlo giancarlo
aquilini che è un pianista che nella
compagnia inoltre in particolare ci
accompagna in questo pezzo come avrete
visto usando solo la mano sinistra a
giancarlo appunto è un pianista che
alcuni anni fa per un problema alla mano
destra dopo un momento di di shock punto
ha dovuto arrangiarsi e rifare musica ha
scelto di andare avanti e di fare musica
con la mano sinistra e quindi questo
comunque nello spettacolo ci sono delle
disabilità delle delle assenze ma non
vogliamo che questo sia il fulcro
diciamo dello spettacolo vogliamo
diciamo trasmettere attraverso l'arte
energia e non tanto attraverso appunto a
quelli che sono i limiti questo punto è
la posizione in cui io silvia siamo e
niente questi sono appunto altri pezzi
invece che si vedono
danzare nello spettacolo assenza niente
questo è un inizio spero di una grande
avventura che mi sta mi ha già regalato
tanto e spero che ci regalerà ancora
altrettanto grazie per l'affetto